is from nbc so
i'm just going to read the report
um an update on the monkey pox outbreak
which may or may not come as a surprise
to you
it's from nbc says since the outset of
the global monkey pox outbreak in may
public health and infectious disease
experts have told the public that the
virus is largely transmitting through
skits transmitted through skin-to-skin
contact in particular during sex between
men
now however an expanding cadre of
experts has come to believe that sex
between men itself
both anal as well as oral intercourse is
likely the main driver of global monkey
pox transmission
the skin contact that comes with sex
these experts say is probably much less
of a risk factor
in recent weeks a growing body of
scientific evidence including a trio of
studies published in peer-reviewed
journals as well as reports from
national regional global health
authorities has suggested that that
experts may have framed monkey pox's
typical transmission route precisely
backward
reconceiving the primary risk factors
for transmission is crucial because of
how it may affect guidance on reducing
the risk of infection including the
question of whether demanding that
people with the virus self-isolate has
any substantial impact on transmission
so now they're finally months later
they're finally admitting that oh you
know what this is actually basically a
an std
this is a sexually transmitted disease
after claiming for months that it wasn't
that uh yeah it's almost all gay men
getting this and uh and it tends to be
transmitted
at orgies and that sort of thing um
and it's you know gay men who have uh
14 different sexual partners over the
course of a weekend they're the ones who
are contracting this but it's not an std
it's not it's got nothing to do with gay
sex at all it's just it's it's really
skin skin contact that's what they told
us
and now as nbc is emitting well that's
precisely backwards
and as always
they they want to get away with this
by saying well we didn't know before so
we're just learning as we go along well
no but you did know before
you knew before because i knew
okay i'm not a public health expert i'm
not a doctor i knew because i just have
common sense we all knew
if if we can see this is a disease that
is spreading almost entirely in the gay
community
and that it spreads almost entirely
among men who are having sex with each
other
pretty good indication this is a
sexually transmitted infection
never made any sense to say well no it's
just skin-to-skin and you know well
okay well if that's what it is then why
then
it's then why is it only
transmitting among gay men
what about straight people who have sex
there's skin and skin contact involved
there too
and what about other environments where
there's a lot of close quarter physical
contact what about people going to
concerts or you know in any kind of
really uh crowded venue
where they're brushing up against each
other
if it has nothing to do with sex then
you should see monkey pox outbreaks
happening in all those kinds of
environments but you never did because
it was obvious from the beginning that
this is a sexually transmitted disease
among gay people
which now they finally tell us
because they have to they have no choice
but
this does put
a little bit of a different light on uh
some other recent monkey pox related
stories like this one for example from
the hill do you remember this it says a
medical journal has published evidence
of the first suspected case of human to
pet transmission of the monkey pox virus
a dog living with two men in france who
were infected with the virus beginning
exhibiting symptoms 12 days after they
did the four-year-old male italian
greyhound which had no previous medical
disorders tested positive after showing
symptoms such as lesions and postulates
on its abdomen
now
at the time
the two
gay men apparently who
somehow passed monkey pox onto their dog
they said that it was because they were
co-sleeping with the dog they had a dog
in bed
but now the public health authorities
are telling us that uh just skin-to-skin
or in this case skin defer contact
that's not enough
it is primarily through
i don't know
i mean how do we connect these dots do i
need to spell it out
it's primarily through sexual contact
that this thing is spread
and these two guys gave it to their dog
yeah and even more horrifying than that
actually is uh the stories we've also
seen of children
who are living with adults that have
monkey pox and end up getting monkey pox
themselves
yeah i mean if we lived in a country
that cared at all about kids cps would
be breaking into those homes right away
and carting those kids out
because
this is clear evidence of uh horrible
things happening in those homes
well before you go uh hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated